the majority of licensed medical
physicians practicing medicine the us
today are MDS
also known as medical doctors however
there is also an increasing number of
practicing physicians known as Dios
which means doctors of osteopathic
medicine both are equally licensed to
practice medicine in all 50 states I
want to make one point very clear before
we start one degree is not better than
the other in fact they have so many
similarities you probably take an hour
to cover them this video is gonna focus
only on the differences between an MD
and a deal the most evident difference
between the two is that do is practice
something called om t which is
osteopathic manipulative therapy instead
of just telling you I'd much rather show
you
come on osteopathic manipulation is a
hands-on therapeutic tool whereby
manipulating the body's own tissues can
restore and maintain optimal function
and it's a low risk conservative measure
that can be used in place of medication
and surgery and it treats all types of
ailments everything from low back pain
to something more complex like
congestive heart failure take a deep
breath in deep breath out how's that
feel really good in osteopathic medical
school there's a heavy emphasis place on
the holistic medical approach now what
does that mean it means an extra focus
on the body's own ability to heal itself
a focus on prevention and a focus on the
whole patient instead of just a disease
process just because there's a heavier
emphasis place on this holistic model in
osteopathic school it doesn't mean that
MDS don't practice with this model as
well there are plenty of MDS who treat
with the whole patient philosophy in
mind those first two differences were
just differences in medical school
training now let's move on to residency
which is arguably the most important
part of medical training in order for a
residency program to be considered
legitimate needs to be authorized by an
Accreditation Council and currently
there are two accreditation counselors
one for MDS and one for do z/os can
train under either Accreditation Council
however md's can only train under the MD
banner come 2020 those two accreditation
councils will merge and allow residents
to train under unify
council further strengthening in my
point that there are becoming less and
less differences between the two degrees
now how about practicing internationally
well here MDS have a distinct advantage
as they're able to practice medicine in
more countries than do currently about
50 countries allow full medical
licensing for us trained EOS
with more countries allowing restricted
practicing as well this restriction
stems from the confusion created by
European trained osteopaths
who aren't medical doctors but are only
trained in manipulation of the
musculoskeletal system however the AOA
has been making great strides in
educating foreign governments about us
trained osteopathic doctors now what
about the applicants to get into an MD
or do program is extremely competitive
with the number of applicants and score
requirements rising each year it's
important to note that do schools do
accept a non-traditional Medical School
applicant those who are going into
medicine as their second career or
perhaps later in life or don't have a
scientific background also the GPA MCAT
combo required for admission is slightly
lower for do schools but that gap is
closing each year interestingly because
there are less do schools despite the
lower requirements it's still more
competitive to get into a deal school a
couple more differences there's a 9 to 1
ratio of m.d. studios out there with
about a hundred thousand do is in active
practice and to a higher percentage of
dio's go into primary care specialties
like family medicine ob/gyn or
pediatrics me personally I chose the do
route because I'm a fan of treating the
patient as a whole and the prevention
aspect plus it never hurts to have a
hands-on tool like OMT bottom line is
when you're picking your doctor you
should focus less on their degree and
more on their communication skills
knowledge bedside manner and experience
[Music]